defenders of the w-h-o emerge after
President Trump calls out the
organization governor Rhonda census of
Florida is owed an apology by the media
and Elizabeth Warren would love to
dictate how businesses operate in
exchange for keeping them alive I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your data from prying
eyes at expressive VPN comm slash event
all righty well let's begin with the
continuing big news of the last week
this week and a half
states are following toward Trenton
Florida's late and the reason for this
is because you're not seeing massive
optics and massive spikes
in cases and deaths in Florida and
Georgia in fact you're seeing a downtick
Georgia particularly the positives as a
percentage of the greater number of
tests that are currently being taken and
this is why all 50 states have reopened
it to some degree according to the New
York Times Connecticut was among the
last states to take a plunge back to
business on Wednesday its stay-at-home
order lifted and stores museums and
offices were allowed to reopen not far
away in New Jersey the reopening has
been more limited with only curbside
pickup at retail stores and allowances
for certain industries the contrast
illustrates the dynamic playing out
across the country as governors grapple
with how to handle a pandemic mag hums
with no political playbook states in the
Northeast and on the west coast as well
as democratic-led states in the Midwest
have moved the slowest toward reopening
several governor's taking a
county-by-county approach by contrast
several states in the south opened
earlier and more fully though social
distancing requirements were put in
place restaurant salons gyms and other
businesses have been open in Georgia for
several weeks there has not been the
predicted spike we keep hearing next
week will be the spike in Georgia it has
now been a month since Georgia moved
toward reopening in a very significant
way there has not yet been the spike
that was predicted now you would see
presumably an uptick in positive numbers
of cases because people aren't
associating once again but it has not
been this overwhelming wave that we were
supposedly going to hear about you see
no isolated cases where churches for
example have had to shut down there was
one in Texas I believe there was one in
Georgia both of which shut down after
people got too close to one another and
a couple people who died and a couple
people died but that is not particularly
shocking again once you let people out
of lockdown and they are associating
with one another then you are likely to
see a little bit more transmission of
the virus that does not mean you are
overwhelming the health care system
which of course was the goal of lockdown
in the first place was to prevent the
overwhelming alaska has now announced it
will go even further on Tuesday governor
Mike Dunleavy said he would lift
restrictions on businesses by the end of
the week allowing restaurants bars gyms
and others return to full capacity as
because Alaska has not been hard hit in
any way sports and recreational
activities will also be allowed ee-vie
said it will all be open just like it
was prior to the virus he said social
distancing strategies would be
commended but not required even as it
plans to it as announced plans to ease
restrictions on residents Alaska said it
was maintaining its requirement that
travelers arriving in the state state
quarantine for 14 days in keeping
visitor restrictions at senior centers
and prisons all of which makes perfect
sense right once your state has lowered
the curve then preventing people who
have this thing from entering your state
makes perfect sense this is happening
all over the world also protecting your
senior citizens and protecting your
jails and places where people are in
close proximity makes perfect sense as
well again the people who are being
hardest hit by all of this are the
seniors and we now have some statistics
that bear out exactly who is being hit
so avec Roy over at free op which is an
organization dedicated to free-market
economic the foundation for research on
equal opportunity
avec Roy has now put out a thread about
the risk factors by population like how
much more deadly is the flu than kovat
for various age groups and it turns out
that if you're looking at young people
the flu is way more deadly when I talk
about young people I'm talking about
people who are under the age of 25 if
you're under age 25 the flu is
significantly more deadly to you then
cove at 19 in fact it is 17 times more
deadly to you then cove at 19 if you
assume 150,000 deaths will occur from
cover 19 over the course of the of this
season of the sea then what you're
looking at is the flu being about 17
times more deadly than the coronavirus
for people who are under a year for
babies is about 20 times more deadly if
you're under 4 it is about 7 times more
deadly if you're between 5 and 14 and
it's about 1.3 times more deadly if
you're between 15 and 24 now once you
get 25 then cove it starts to be more
deadly than the flu once you hit 25 then
it then cove it is about 2 times more
deadly than the flu if you're under the
age of 34 again this takes into account
everybody right this is not there's
pre-existing conditions too so if you're
healthy then obviously your risk factors
are lower so kovat is about twice as
deadly as the flu for people who are
between 25 and 34 it's about three times
as deadly as the flu for people between
35 and 44 it is about 3.6 times as
deadly if you are between 45 and 54 it
is about 3.8 five times more at least
about four times as deadly as the flu
between 55 and 64 and then 3.5 for 65 to
74 and then shockingly it's only about
2.6 times more deadly than the flu for
people between 75 and 84
why because it turns out that those
people died at extraordinarily high
rates anyway and again one of the things
that we are recognizing here is that the
as we start to study the underlying
statistics people in nursing homes died
and extraordinary rates anyway they
represent about 0.5 percent of the
American population they represent
nearly 20% of all deaths in a given year
in the American population so an uptick
at nursing homes is not exactly a
shocker that is the the most vulnerable
group in our population always has been
if you're over 85 by the way it's only
about one point seven times more deadly
than the flu covered 19
according to avec Roy over at free-up he
says here's another way to think about
the very low risk to children so we'd
never closed at schools Sweden has one
of the lowest pediatric infection rates
in the industrialized world and exactly
one pediatric death from Kobe 19 so when
you hear politicians saying we can't
reopen the schools well unless you have
people blowing the schools and then
immediately like being dropped off at
the nursing home probably you don't have
to worry about this so much children are
really not the the disease vector for it
this thing not only that we have some
very good news in terms of the way this
thing spreads and I'm shocked frankly
that this is not the top story in the
country considering how much people have
been worried about cleaning off surfaces
for example we'll get to that in just
one second first let's talk about now
being an excellent time take care of
your mind and body you wanna be as
healthy as humanly possible for a
variety of reasons and you want to be
healthy in mind as well lockdown it
ain't good for the soul and this means
that you have to take provision that
really changes the way you think now why
not take advantage of a bad situation
why don't let a don't let a crisis go to
waste instead why don't you make
yourself stronger make yourself stronger
mentally make yourself more fit
physically I'm talking about using new
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale it's
about building healthier habits and
feeling better about yourself if fitting
into that favorite pair of jeans is your
goal that's great but there are many
reasons you might want to practice
self-care every person is different
everyone is different so Numa just to
your lifestyle they teach you the
psychology behind the decisions you make
and then help you keep track of
everything from workouts and steps to
analyzing your diet and recommending
healthy recipes you have to adopt a new
way of life and Noom helps you do that
noon is the habit changing solution no
food is good bad or off-limits at noon
teaches moderation can use it can be
used in conjunction with many
preexisting popular diets if you want
we're all strapped for time and so Numa
asks you to commit about 10 minutes a
day for it yourself you don't have to
change it all in one day
small steps make big progress I've been
using new myself I've taken off about 10
12 pounds over the course of this
demek sign up for your trial today at
noon and om comm slash appear oh you
have nothing to lose visit Noom comm
slash appear to start your trial today
that's n o om calm / Schapiro Numa calm
/ super I've recommended it to my
parents as well new mom / appear ok so
here is a good piece of news according
to the blaze the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention has updated its
guidance on Coppa 19 to say the disease
does not spread easily on contaminated
surfaces the disease has always been
thought to spread mainly through
person-to-person contact by respiratory
droplets produced when an infected
person costs sneezes or talks up until
recently the CDC was maintaining the
virus could also spread through contact
with contaminated surfaces now the CDC
says the virus does not spread easily in
other ways in other words if somebody
doesn't sneeze on you or cough on you or
talk real close to you for a prolonged
period of time you're probably not
getting this thing right if you if you
just go to the park and you touch a
surface unless someone's sneezed on that
surface like half a second before the
chances are extraordinarily low that
you're gonna end up with kovin 19 the
CDC guidance now says it may be possible
for Kobe 19 to spread in other ways
these are not thought to be the main
ways the virus spreads according to
Yahoo News the guidance used to simply
say that the spread in other ways may be
possible without the added disclaimer
but that is a fairly significant a
fairly significant development much of
the thinking on the viruses spread
through contaminated surfaces stemmed
from a New England Journal of Medicine
study in March that found the virus
could survive in the air for hours and
on certain surfaces for days in April
when the FDA announced customers don't
need to worry about contracting the
virus from grocery packaging the CDC
guidance expressed caution citing the
study but now it turns out based on the
epidemiology according to a senior
scholar at Johns Hopkins center for
health security dr. Amish indulge a
based on the epidemiology we know that
the main way this virus is infecting
people is from direct contact with other
infected people contaminated surfaces
play some role it is likely much smaller
this is a respiratory virus respiratory
viruses largely spread through breathing
in infected respiratory droplets so in
other words wash your hands a lot don't
like your face immediately after
touching surfaces but if you pick up an
Amazon package at the front door
the chances are extraordinarily high
you're not getting Koba 19 from the
Amazon package over at the front door
and this is why you're starting to see
many states now considering reopening
schools and camps The Wall Street
Journal has a piece today talking about
how various countries have decided to
deal with all of this they talked about
the fact that there have been a few
cases of a
kan'u condition that is similar to
Kawasaki disease but it's very rare in
fact it's rare enough that likely won't
affect most decisions to reopen camps in
schools according to health and policy
experts many experts said parents should
be reassured that this that this affects
an extremely small percentage of
children has caused a very few deaths
Stephen Kearney the chief of pediatric
critical care of medicine at new
york-presbyterian Morgan Stanley
Children's Hospital in Columbia says
it's probably hundreds of thousands of
kids in the New York area who've been
exposed to the virus it seems like a
really small number of people are
getting this the hospitals had about
1440 children with this particular
syndrome they're treated with steroids
and they usually recover in three to
four days and then follow up with a
cardiologist
so camps are are now considering whether
they're gonna reopen for the summer and
again this is all good news
hey it's funny because listen we're all
nervous it you know it's hard we people
get used to the situation there and once
the government tells you that you are
only safe if you lock down it's
nerve-racking when people say you can
open back up again but pretty much a lot
of the news has been very very good and
this is true in Europe as well according
to bloomberg officials in continental
Europe's major economies are closely
monitoring coronavirus data for signs of
resurgence and infections as
restrictions on daily life are phased
out countries must focus on more than
daily case numbers and death tolls
because those are lagging indicators a
better guide might come from the length
of lines outside the doctor's office or
surveys conducted at random however
Europe's coronavirus spread seems to be
in check even as the lock downs are
loosened over in Europe and again in
America people are picking this back up
in in Europe by the way in in Denmark
Danish bars and cafes are completely
back in business social distancing has
now been scaled back to 1 meter which is
a little over 3 feet it means more
customers can now be seated at
restaurants because it turns out it's
very difficult to fill a restaurant when
everybody is seated 62 part the 2 meters
was a big issue it didn't allow us to
have enough revenue said Jacob niver the
chairman of Denmark's restaurant and
cafe Association he thinks most
restaurants will be ready to open this
week face masks aren't compulsory
they're already a rare sight in Denmark
groups of up to 10 friends can already
sit together for pubs there will be no
more customers propping up at the bar
they aren't allowed to face staff for
more than 15 minutes mainly cuz they
don't want people breathing on the staff
on a continuous level but we are
starting to see you know countries all
over the world open up so when people on
the left in the United States suggest
that it's crazy that southern states are
opening up just
come in and just just point out that
Europe is doing exactly the same thing
and they're not singing up ticking cases
meanwhile over in Ohio Governor Mike
DeWine has lifted Ohio's safe at home
order according to Cleveland comm more
of Ohio's mandatory restrictions to curb
the spread of coronavirus will be cut
short according to governor DeWine some
key social distancing rules including a
ban on most mass gatherings restrictions
on bars and restaurants will still
remain mandatory the language with the
new advisory order was not immediately
available the document had not yet been
signed but twine says the state will
continue to enforce a number of
mandatory rules most notably
requirements that patrons at bars and
restaurants must remain seated while
eating and drinking in state at least
six feet away from others also Ohio's
ban on most gatherings of ten or more
people will remain in place but
obviously everybody is moving toward
reopening and this is obvious across the
country and so here's the question when
does Ron de santis get his apology
the Florida governor now it's amazing to
see the lengths to which the media will
go to try and portray Florida as a giant
failure despite the fact that Florida
has nearly the same population as New
York almost identical populations to New
York in terms of the number of people
and they've experienced what 1/10 112
the number of deaths there's not been a
major outbreak in Florida there are no
there were some cases there were not
tremendous numbers of deaths in Florida
their deaths per million people are
about the same as California for example
where we've had no major outbreaks in
California and yet the media have been
all over two stances from day one
suggesting the stance didn't know what
he was doing it turns out to stance it's
got a right the latest attempt by the
way by the media to get to Santos was so
obviously stupid that I pointed this out
yesterday and then it turns out of
course the story fell apart you could
say I talked about this yesterday on the
program there was a story from Miami
Herald yesterday suggesting that
Florida's data analysts had been fired
because she was attempting to bring the
truth to the people and to Sansa stepped
in and big-footed her to prevent her
from bringing the actual news about her
own virus to the people now it turns out
she was fired for insubordination
according to the Post Gazette calm
facing an explosive from the Sarasota
Herald Tribune in Florida facing an
explosive charge that his administration
is manipulating coronavirus data to help
make the case for reopening Florida
governor Rhonda stances played down the
controversy Tuesday as a non-issue
health experts say that the milestone in
Florida they topped 2,000 deaths
should serve as a sobering reminder to
exercise caution as the state reopens
DeSantis has presented his reopening
plan is safe and step by step but the
accusations leveled by Rebecca Jones
were
undermining that push except for the
fact that Jones apparently was not
telling the truth
but she suggested that there's gonna be
a cover-up of data the article itself
the original article itself said there
had been no cover-up of the data thus
ANSYS said Tuesday Jones sends an email
to her supervisor saying that her
comments were being misinterpreted the
Sansa said I don't know who she is they
gave me an email she sent to her
supervisor said that oh I may have said
something that was misinterpreted I said
they've got a team working on it now
what I meant is I don't expect the same
level of accessibility is that they are
busy and can't answer every single email
they get right away and then it was
ridiculous that I managed to do it in
the first place and then I was tired and
needed a break from working two months
straight okay that is not what she said
in her original public letter but she
said in her original public letter is
that the accessibility would be limited
because of a cover-up and now she's
backtracking on it
the Sansa said that the state's Cove a
19 dashboard is a heck of a tool he said
I'm proud of the folks who work on it
Jones told the Florida today she was
fired on Monday and then she said that
she faced blowback because she manually
refused to change data to drum up
support for the plan to reopen the
governor's office then released a
statement saying Jones was terminated
quote after a repeated course of
insubordination
including her unilateral decisions to
modify the department's coven 19
dashboard without input or approval from
the epidemiological team or her
supervisors he said accuracy and
transparency are always indispensable
especially certain an unprecedented
public health emergency like Copa 19
having someone's disruptive cannot be
tolerated during this pandemic which led
the department to determine it was best
to terminate her employment I mean that
that's amazing okay so basically the
media ran with this bullcrap story
because they wanted to get to Santa's
meanwhile by the way just a quick note
the states that are actually changing
their Dana now our democratic states
governor Gretchen Whitmer in Michigan
Gretchen Whitmer she announced that
Michigan would now quietly uptick the
number of deaths that they estimate are
due to kovin 19 in the state according
to Lynn Sutphin a state health
spokesperson the state this week will
start reporting probable cases she said
that would be a death where the death
certificate liskova 19 disease as a
cause of death or a significant
condition contributing to death without
a positive Kovan 19 confirmed at lab
results in other words most states have
been reporting probable kovat 19 deaths
its cover 19 deaths Michigan has not so
far so that means that they have under
counted the number of deaths by probably
thousands in Michigan
in Colorado a state representative
called for an investigation after the
state acknowledged that it was counting
as Cova 19 deaths cases in which the
disease was not listed as the cause of
death that they had tested positive for
coronavirus so you're starting to see
colorado reversing course in april new
york city began counting probable deaths
in which Cova 19 was listed as a cause
of death but there wasn't a positive
test says just a mess out there
meanwhile again Ron DeSantis he didn't
handle things rolling in Florida right
he's been raked over the coals whitmer
has been propped up as a hero and even
though she's been awful
she's been far too restrictive on
counties in in Michigan like far too
restrictive like you can't buy seeds you
can't buy you can't buy car seats at the
local target you can't you can't put a
motor boat on the lake but you can put a
rowboat around the lake like idiotic
stuff like that she's a hero Andrew
Cuomo's a hero Rhonda stances apparently
is the bad guy we'll get to Rhonda
Sanchez in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that sleep is hard
to come by these days you're at home a
lot with your kids I know I am too and
it is stressful
it means the gets a bed later it means
that you get up earlier and it means
that when you're on that mattress it had
better be comfortable because if it is
not comfortable you're not getting any
sleep this is why you need a helix sleep
mattress helix has a quiz it takes just
two minutes to complete
matches your body type and sleep
preferences so the perfect mattress for
you whether you're a side sleeper hot
sleeper with like a plush or firm been
with helix there's no more confusion and
no more compromising helix is rated the
number one mattress by GQ and Wired
magazine CNN called it the most
comfortable mattress they've ever slept
on and that is not fake news just go to
helix sleep calm / men take their two
minutes leave poise they will match you
to a customized mattress that gives you
the best sleep of your life it does for
me my wife and I took the two minutes
sleep quiz this mattress is just
phenomenal they've got a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free so you really have
nothing to lose they'll even pick it up
for you if you don't love it but I
promise you're going to helix is
offering up to $200 off all mattress
orders for our listeners just go to
helix sleep calm / band that is helix
sleep calm / Ben and get up to 200 bucks
off helix lucam so I spend get a
mattress personalized for you because
why don't you have a mattress that is
not personalized for you I mean there's
a free country people helix sleep calm /
Ben go check them out right now so where
does run - San Cisco - I get his apology
the answer is the media will not be
apologizing at anytime in the near
future rich Lowry has a good piece in
interview with Ron DeSantis he says in
irony of the national coverage of the
corona virus is that
the same time the census was being made
into a villain New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo was being elevated as a hero even
though the censuses approach to nursing
homes was obviously superior to that of
Cuomo Florida went out of its way to get
Cova 19 positive people out of nursing
homes while New York went out of its way
to get them in a policy now widely
acknowledged to have been a debacle the
media didn't have their eyes on the ball
the day the media had their first big
freaking about floor was March 15 sense
DeSantis which was there were people on
Clearwater Beach and it was this big
deal
that same day we signed the executive
order to one man visitation in nursing
homes and to ban the reintroduction of a
kovat positive patient back into a
nursing home
the Sansa's has been used by the
obsession with Florida's beaches when
they reopened in Jacksonville it was a
big national story usually relayed with
a dire tone
Jacksonville has almost no covert
activity outside of a nursing home
context he said their hospitalizations
are down ICU is down since the beaches
opened a month ago but nobody talks
about it it's like okay we just move on
to the next target perhaps more
understandably the villages the iconic
senior community was a focus of media
worries according to the Santas as of
last weekend there had not been a single
residents of the villages in the
hospital for Kovan 19 for about a week
at one point the infection rate in the
villages was so low state officials were
worried they were missing something
say says I got the University of Florida
to do a study they did 100 and they did
1,200 asymptomatic seniors of the
villages not one came back positive
which was really incredible so what
exactly did the census do well first he
looked at South Korea he said it was
pretty dramatic the extents which this
was concentrated in an older age groups
I think the first real fresh set of
South Korea numbers I looked at they had
no fatalities under 30 80 percent of
them were 70 or above it was really
dramatic then there was Italy he says I
think a lot of policymakers in the u.s.
acted like Italy would happen in the US
when you looked under the hood in Italy
there were huge differences there were
reasons why that part of Italy fared as
poorly as it is I think the median age
fatality was like 82 in those areas of
northern Italy so we looked at that that
really helped inform the strategy to
focus most of our efforts on the at-risk
of groups he was hesitant about sweeping
lockdowns because there wasn't a lot of
precedent for them also they didn't put
much stock in tire predictions he says
we kind of lost confidence early on in
the models we looked at them closely but
how can you rely on something when it
says you're peaking in a week and the
next day you've already peaked Florida
was also able to handle this better
because they've dealt with natural
disasters many times and Florida
protected the nursing homes because they
have a disproportionate number of
nursing home residents in Florida Mary
Mayhew who heads the nursing home effort
says whose clear to me
there were much higher standards related
to infection control being outlined by
the federal CDC that well exceeded what
our nursing homes traditionally have
been expected to adhere to so he never
had false expectations inspectors and
assessment teams visited nursing homes
the state homes in on facilities where
may who said we had historically sighted
around infection control we use that to
prioritize our visits to those
facilities understanding that the
guidance from the CDC was changing
quickly Florida required all staff into
any worker that entered to be screened
for Cova delemus temperature checks
anyone symptomatic would simply not be
allowed to go in and they required staff
to wear PPE he says we recognized these
facilities were not prepared to deal
with something like this so he sent a
total of 10 million masks just to our
long-term care facilities a million
gloves half a million face shields ok so
his hands has handled this exactly the
way he was supposed to by the way Mary
Mayhew who again was in charge of this
effort said she had calls with hospitals
every day she said I would hear the same
comments and questions around we need to
get individuals returned back to nursing
homes we drew a hard line early on I
said repeatedly to the hospital to the
CEOs to the discharge planners to the
medical officers I understand for 20
years has been ingrained especially
because of Medicare reimbursement to get
individuals in and out that is not our
focus I'm not sending anyone back to a
nursing home who has the slightest risk
of being positive
she said we said let's not have two
cases become 20 or 5 become 50 if you
don't manage the individual as you were
turn them back he'll have far more being
transferred back to the hospital make he
was unmovable on the question ok so
Florida handled this exactly right and
Florida was blamed because the media
hadn't agenda from beginning to end here
and that agenda continues to be carried
out despite the fact that the facts no
longer support the agenda you could at
least make the argument that this was
good-hearted at the beginning because
everybody was risk-averse but what
happens when it turns out that New
York's freakin disaster area and that
Florida is fine because Florida handle
it the way you're supposed to and the
way that I've been talking about for
literally months protect the elderly
protect the nursing homes recognize
differential risk assessments but
instead Florida was the bad guy here
truly truly incredible in just a second
when you got two more agenda driven
politics this time on China we'll get
there in just one second first let's
talk about the fact that you are at home
right now that means that your IT
department cannot protect your online
activity you need to protect your own
online activity what is the best way to
accomplish this well you should be using
expressvpn as well you know I am a big
advocate of expressvpn why very easy to
all on your computer even your mom or
dad can do it grandma grandpa can do it
it's really simple and now their
internet activity is protected with the
click of a button it's not gonna slow
down your internet connection which is a
big problem with a lot of VPNs and also
they're not gonna be reselling your data
if you get a free VPN service online
very often those people are actually
taking your data packaging it and
reselling it to advertisers you don't
want that instead go check out
expressvpn right now also gonna protect
yourself from hackers which is a very
very big thing these days hackers are
making tons of moolah cuz everybody's
online twenty seven hours a day my only
question is why haven't you gotten
expressvpn yet visit my special link
right now expressvpn comm slash man and
next for three months of expressvpn for
free protect your internet today with
the VPN I trust to keep them idea too
safe
that's expr ESS VPN comm /ban expressvpn
comm slash man go check them out right
now expressvpn comm slash pin and you
get an extra three months for free and
you're keeping yourself protected so
what exactly is the downside alright
meanwhile the Trump administration is
pointing out that oh yeah by the way the
w-h-o is garbage cheap so yesterday
President Trump
issued a letter to the WH o saying we
need systemic change inside the WH o
because you guys didn't just blow this
you blues royally you're taking all of
your advice from the Chinese government
and let's just be real about this the
Chinese government is a flaming trash
heap the Chinese government is in evil
governments Ronald Reagan suggested that
the Soviet government was the evil
empire the Chinese government is in fact
an evil empire is an evil government it
is a government that the jails a million
we Gers for the crime of being Muslim it
is a government that keeps a billion
people in repression it is a government
that will maybe we'll certainly jail you
and maybe kill you if you cross them it
is a government that is trying to claw
back all of its treaty obligations to
Hong Kong is a government that would
love nothing better than to take over
Taiwan a free and independent Taiwan it
is a government that lies routinely to
the world population it is government
that is it it is a full-on dictatorship
the fact that anybody treats China as
the legitimate world power as opposed to
an illegitimate government that is a
world power is beyond me China is an
evil empire it has been an evil empire
for a very long time there involved in
the forced abortion of literally
millions and millions of children they
were involved in the forced
sterilization of hundreds of thousands
of women this is a government
there one there one child policy spans
1970 to 2015 this is an evil evil gum
it's an evil government and the fact
that people are defending that
government because they hate from so
much is truly astonishing to me
so how evil is this government so Mike
Pompeo gave a congratulations to the
Taiwanese president on her second term
she sent a message to presidents I and
when on her inauguration he was the
first US Secretary of State to applaud a
Taiwanese president on their election
according to the Chinese government
which demonstrates by the way how
pathetic the American government has
been on this issue for a very long time
Taiwan ought to be free and independent
one of the great tragedies of history is
that Mao Zedong won the battle against
Chiang kai-shek would that all of China
were governed by the same people who
governed Taiwan not the other way around
okay so the u.s. issued a
congratulations to Taiwan which by the
way we have a defense obligation to and
the Chinese government immediately said
that Pompeius Mike Pompeo the Secretary
of State his statement seriously
violated the one-china principle F the
one-china principle the one-china
principle is a bunch of crap they say
that it's one one nation I'm sure it's
one China two countries Taiwan is not
China it's not governing the same way as
China Hong Kong is not China which is
why you're seeing tens of thousands of
people out in the streets by the way
under cover of this coronavirus pandemic
China is cracking down on all dissent
inside Hong Kong everybody's ignoring
that remember right before the corona
virus pandemic back in January there's a
lot of talk about repression in Hong
Kong China China is now taking advantage
of the having to crack down and arrest
all of the leaders of that of them
effort against China China took
exceptions Pompeo referring to Thai as
president Pompeyo said in his statement
her reelection by a huge margin shows
she has earned the respect admiration
and trust of the people of Taiwan
he said her courage and vision in
leading Taiwan's vibrant democracies and
inspirations of the region in the world
as we look toward the future I'm
confident that with presidents I at the
helm our partnership with Taiwan will
continue to flourish China immediately
got angry because they said that it's
very bad that we pointed out that
someone was elected in Taiwan better the
leader should be selected by the
Politburo and there should be no
elections apparently the Ministry the
Foreign Ministry of China said China
urges the USI to immediately correct its
mistakes the Chinese side will take
necessary countermeasures to respond to
the above-mentioned erroneous actions by
the US side the US side should bear the
consequences arising therefrom
consequences arising there
from how about you bear some
consequences for unleashing a pandemic
that's going to kill probably a million
people on planet earth and destroy the
entire world economy for a year maybe
you should bear the consequences of that
how about you you should bear the
consequences of taking control of the
w-h-o by the way there's some pretty
incestuous ties between the Chinese
government and the w-h-o including
high-ranking members of the WHI being
married two members of the Chinese
government but according to the New York
Times
president Trump's angry demands for
punitive action against the w-h-o were
rebuffed on Tuesday by the
organization's other members who decided
to conduct an impartial independent
examination of the WH o--'s response to
the corona virus pandemic and a
four-page later late Monday night from
threatened to permanently cut off u.s.
funding to the wh o unless had committed
two major substantive improvements
within 30 days that was a significant
escalation of his repeated attempts to
blame the WH o in China for the spread
of the virus and deflect responsibility
for his own handling of a crisis that
has killed more than 90,000 people in
the United States let me just point out
how disgusting the New York Times
coverage is here
Trump points out the wh o is a disaster
area they are a disaster area they lied
to the public for weeks about human to
human transmission they suggested that
China was handling this thing better
than anybody else the channels being
fully transparent dr. Ted throws is a
disaster area at the wh oh I'm a medical
doctor by the way okay the fact is that
criticizing the w-h-o in China is not a
deflecting tactic it is a reality of
life but the way that the New York Times
covers that that's an editorial decision
right they say that when Trump rips on
China in the w-h-o it's to quote deflect
responsibility for his own handling of
the crisis or alternatively it is to
criticize China for unleashing this
pandemic around the world knowing full
damn well that there was human-to-human
transmission and allowing five million
citizens to leave the Wuhan area while
they knew that this disease was
spreading widely representatives of the
organization's member nations rallied
around the w-h-o there's a damn shock
you mean that Russia and China resisted
the United States the European Union
chided Trump's heated rhetoric even as
they acknowledged the need to review the
wh o--'s respond as the virus spread
from China to the rest of the world
that's because the EU is filled with
bunch of pansies who are afraid to
stands up to the Chinese government
because the Chinese government does a
lot of business with them same deal as
the EU refusing to stand up to Iran when
the United States under President Trump
was the only country willing to stand up
to Iran public health experts noted
Trump's threats to withdraw from the
organization
and permanently halt funding ignored the
reality that any such moves would
require the consent of Congress but the
president's continued attacks on the
whu-oh said experts o experts said wow
you know unnamed experts saying things
whoa color me really concerned
threatened to hobble the organization
and seriously damage international
efforts to combat the virus which was
more damaging Trump threatening to cut
off funding unless they get their act
together or the w-h-o never having their
act together in the first place
yesterday president from said the who
has to clean up their act
he's not talking about the the rock
musical Tommy here's President Trump
going after the WHO letter but basically
they have to clean up their act
they have to do a better job they have
to be much more fair to other countries
including the United States so we're not
going to be involved with them anymore
we'll do it a separate way okay so he is
exactly right about all of us and what's
amazing about this is Trump is such a
polarizing figure for the media that the
media immediately weak to defend China
the only reason to blame China the only
reason to blame the Chinese government
which again is evil
the only reason to blame them is because
the is because Trump is very bad at his
job now again should we point out at
this point that the deaths per million
in the United States stands below most
European nations outside of Germany is
it okay to point out that the best
battery of this thing mainly happened in
New York let some how florida handled it
okay Texas hands on okay even California
handled it okay Washington State had an
early outbreak and then got it under
control is it okay to point out that
Trump got the ventilators where they
need to go and then right now we have
more testing capacity than people
looking to be tested are we allowed to
point to any of that out or is it just
all Trump ban all the time so Susan Rice
the garbage National Security Advisor
who lied to the American public
repeatedly about the Benghazi attacks
which I know we're not supposed to talk
about the scandal of the Benghazi
attacks in which the State Department
routinely turned down requests for
additional security in Libya and then
tried to pretend that the attack was
spontaneous and not planned and was in
fact driven by a YouTube video I know
we're supposed to pretend that was not a
big deal at all and you know big deal
yeah Benghazi and then you put it in a
tweet and you put it with letters
vertically we're supposed to pretend
that was not a big deal Susan Rice won a
national TV and lied about it like a
thousand times
now she is considered a possible
president
vice presidential pick for Joe Biden and
we're gonna get to Susan Rice on China
by the way if this is a battle that
Trump has to fight this is like the best
election battle ever for Trump if this
election comes down to Trump pointing
out that China's garbage heap and the
Democrats suggesting that Trump is just
a meanie for targeting China that is a
battle Trump wins every time
we're gonna get some more of this in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that now is a fantastic time to
save money why would you not save money
if it were free to do so if it didn't
cost you any money
to save money this is where honey comes
in with honey the coupons in savings
come to you honey is a free online
shopping tool teach you money online
honey will automatically find the best
promo codes and then apply them to your
cart that makes online shopping finally
feel as easy as it's supposed to be
imagine your shopping when one of your
favorite sites targeted Best Buy
sephora's Macy's eBay Walmart Amazon
when you checkout his little box drops
down where all you have to do is click
apply coupons I probably saved thousands
of dollars at this point just from
having honey running in the background
of my computer you wait a few seconds
for it to scan every promo code on the
internet and then you just watch the
prices drop honey has found over 18
million members over two billion dollars
in savings I really like the other day I
bought my son a birthday gift I will
tell you what it was it was a fantastic
birthday gift it was in fact a mu it was
an electric land speeder from Star Wars
kid is totally into it I saved a bunch
of money on it because I used honey not
using honey is literally passing up free
money it is free to use it installs in
just a few seconds plus it is backed by
PayPal so you know you can trust it get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
pen that is join honey calm slash pen
again you're saving money for literally
just hitting a button there's really no
reason not to do it join honey calm
slash Ben can we're gonna get more into
the Democratic Defense of China like
what are they thinking we're gonna get
to that in just a second but first let's
point out the double tumblr is back baby
it's back and better than other ever but
it is only available for our most
exclusive membership tier all access the
all access membership tier is our
premium or premier level of membership
also premium level of membership all
access members get to participate in all
access life that is our brand-new
interactive programming feature scene
featuring running one of us daily water
houses we hang out with you each night
all access members get to join us for
real-time and Q&A discussions available
on both the website and the daily wire
app and all access membership now
includes two two there they're
replicating it's like we've got the Star
Wars replicator over here the Star Trek
replicator Star Wars
Star Trek replicator 2 one thing left is
chairs tumblers the tumblers are
overflowing with tears at the thought of
this offer people finally all Isis
members get all the benefits of all the
other membership tears to get the ad
from ad free website experience access
to all of our live broadcasts show
library access to the mailbag the full
three hours of the ben shapiro show
every day along with dedicated
editorials from moi so head on over to
daily wire.com slash subscribe join all
access at 15% off with coupon code
Shapiro right now that is daily wire.com
slash subscribe we will see you there
you're listening it's and largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so one of the funny things is watching
the New York Times editorial side decide
the New York Times objective media
coverage so the objective media coverage
so much objectivity so much media isn't
it's so much journalism I mean just
incredible levels of objective
journalism ain't happening over at the
New York Times so they'll actually
headline things like deflecting from his
own incompetence Trump blames China and
that'll be their objective news story
and then you head on over to the op-ed
page and why there's Susan Rice just
writing the same thing so Susan Rice
says there's a long history of American
presidential candidates using China as a
campaign cudgel from Bill Clinton
blasting President George HW Bush in
1992 with for dealing with the Chinese
premier known as the butcher of Beijing
- Donald Trump's 2016 attack that the
Obama administration had allowed China
to rape the United States while Hillary
Clinton was Secretary of State this
election year China bash will reach a
new level as mr. Trump seeks to
capitalize on high voter disapproval of
China
Beijing's failure to contain the
coronavirus and persistent bilateral
tensions between our countries well it
seems like those are all relevant
factors like the fact that again China
is in evil evil government that has
released virus and then tried to blame
the United States for the release of the
virus and also that their oppressive
horrifying regime but according to Susan
Rice Trump is a Meany desperate to
obscure the reality of more than 90,000
American deaths and 36 million
unemployed amid mr. Trump utterly
incompetent handling of the pandemic
Republicans have no better strategy than
a play the China card the Republicans
are executing a 57 page campaign memo
that recommends branding opponents soft
on China and reveals their rationale for
repeated refrains of China virus and
Wuhan lab me again this was released
from Wuhan we don't know if it happened
from a Wuhan lab if we don't believe
that it was released intentionally or
that it was created in the Wuhan lab
that is not the suggestion but China
won't allow any investigation and in
fact his threatened sanctions against
places like Australia for suggesting
some sort of independent investigation
but Susan Rice is really mad about this
she says that it's very we cannot we
cannot be so mean to China first she
tries to claim that Biden is is really
harsh on China which is hilarious I mean
truly hilarious Joe Biden flew to China
with his son and then his son received
like a billion dollar investment in a
fund in which he was that he was running
well Biden was vice president like they
flew on Air Force two to China he and
hunter dead and
picked up bags of cash this is something
that hunter frequently did obviously but
says Susan Rice mr. Trump will run his
standard play trying to deflect
responsibility for his monumental
failings by dishonestly projecting on to
mr. Biden his own weakness on China from
seemingly will do anything to win in
November
his China gambit may be the least of it
still campaigning on China well a
well-worn strategy is particularly
dangerous in these tense times when it
feels anti-ageing hostility at home and
anti-american sentiments abroad okay so
this is gonna be the other angle that is
run by the media is that every time
Trump pinches China it's because he
wants Chinese Americans targeted which
is absurd Trump has repeatedly talked
about how stupid that is and it is
indeed stupid but it's it is amazing to
watch how the objective journalism
inside takes its cues directly from the
op-ed page over at the New York Times by
the way talking about soft on China
never forget that it was Joe Biden who
suggested that a travel ban on citizens
coming from Wuhan and China that that
was actually xenophobic hysteria here
was Joe Biden doing just that back in
January a national emergency and you
know worldwide alert the American people
need to have a president who they can
trust what he says about it that he is
going to act rationally about it and
almost like this this is where credibly
a president is most needed as he
explains what we should and should not
do this is no time for Donald Trump's
record of hysteria xenophobia hysterical
xenophobia nuts it's time for Joe Biden
to go back to sleep means he needs his
nap or he gets a little tired in the
middle of these events Rachel Maddow by
the way over at MSNBC doing the same
routine she was full-on defending the
whu-oh this is where we are and what is
her basis for defense her basis for
defense he's in a four page letter there
is one error they cite the Lancet
medical journal to the notion that this
thing may have been spreading since
November or December there was in fact a
report that this thing may have been
spreading from November or December
Lancet came out and said we don't want
to be used as a tool against the w-h-o
because all these medical organizations
rely on the WHI work with the w-h-o
Rachel Maddow that went on a rant last
night about how we have to stop being
means at the w-h-o and Trump is just
terrible for being means at the whu-oh
honestly if you want to make this your
campaign that you're gonna defend the
whu-oh and China for their behavior
during this pandemic go for it
I mean really owned it just like owned
it here's Rachel Maddow owning it
president's letter said quote we know
the following the whu-oh consistently
ignored credible reports of the virus
spreading in wuhan in early December
2019 or even earlier including reports
from The Lancet medical journal well The
Lancet medical journal wrote to the
White House today to say oh my god what
are you talking about and paraphrasing
that but that's basically what they mean
here's what they actually said I can
quote it well this statement is
factually incorrect The Lancet published
no report in December 2019 referring to
a virus or outbreak in wuhan or anywhere
else in China okay
that that is true it is also true that
the that The Lancet did report later
that it is possible that there was some
sort of outbreak that took place earlier
than December they say the first reports
of the journal published were on January
24 2020 and a payment by Challen Hank
and colleagues the first forty-one
patients from Wuhan from with Cova 19
were described the scientists and
physicians who led the study were all
from Chinese institutions they worked
with us quickly to make information
about the new epidemic outbreak and
disease it caused fully and freely
available to an international audience
that that's not what Trump was referring
to but okay fine so let's assume that
was just a blatant error does that does
that invalidate any of the other four
pages of problems that are cited with
with the with the wh oh of course not so
go for it guys I mean really go for it
now that would be a you know Trump going
after China is in fact a a smart a smart
play it is also the morally correct play
I'll tell you what it's not particularly
a smart play is he continued focus on
hydroxychloroquine president Trump
continues to jump on the
hydroxychloroquine thing I'm not sure
exactly why doctors are gonna recommend
what doctors are going to recommend in
his own defense
you know Trump went to his doctor and
the doctor said if you take
hydroxychloroquine with zinc and you
take it with his a--throw myosin then
and there may be some good results and
Trump said that he started taking it
after there was possible exposure at the
White House then somebody said to him
you know there was a study that
suggested that hydroxychloroquine is not
particularly effective so Trump being
Trump he immediately said that
hydroxychloroquine study was a trump
enemy statement which it is not it is
just a study
on come on how's this useful I've worked
with doctors and if you look at the one
survey the only bad survey they were
giving it to people that were in very
bad shape they were very old almost dead
it was a trump enemy statement now if
you look at some of the reports that
came out from Italy they came out from
France they came out for a mother a lot
of our frontline workers take it because
it possibly and I think it does but you
know people are gonna have to make up
their own mind plus it doesn't hurt
people okay so yeah when when he says
that this thing is a trump enemy
statement like that is not useful I'll
tell you what is amazing though is how
the media are and and the Democrats are
fully willing to say anything including
things that are inaccurate in order to
rebut President Trump so Joe Biden for
example he says no doctor has said to
use hydroxychloroquine no doctor has
said to use it truly none because there
are some I am aware of thousands of
people who are taking hydroxychloroquine
in combination with his afro myosin and
zinc I'm like that is it like really
that that is a reality there are lots of
doses that have been prescribed across
the country for a variety of reasons by
many doctors Joe Biden medical Joe Biden
here we are
this is absolutely irresponsible there's
no serious medical personnel out there
saying to use that drug it's
counterproductive it's not gonna help
okay again the the willingness of
anybody to say anything because they
oppose Trump is truly incredible
meanwhile Nancy Pelosi and Trump are in
a teenage school fight so Nancy Pelosi
suggested the other day that Trump was
morbidly obese so we live in a world
where it's okay to call Trump morbidly
obese but call Stacey Abrams a
supermodel which is exciting stuff Nancy
Pelosi then came out after Trump mr.
Trump ripped in door he said Pelosi has
a lot of mental problems alright fair I
guess fair but why are we governed
seriously this is what you chose America
why are we governed by a bunch of people
who appear to have stopped their their
brain development in sixth grade serious
question here's President Trump pointing
out that Pelosi has mental problems and
look into Pelosi responding and then
they say nananana neener-neener and then
they and then they slap each other like
like characters from the Three Stooges
and walk away here's President Trump
these people
SiC Pelosi is a sick woman she's got a
lot of problems a lot of mental problems
we're dealing with people that have to
get their act together for the good of
the country okay and then Nancy Pelosi
responded well I guess he's offended I
guess he's triggered because he's
triggered President Trump here's Nancy
Pelosi very shiny Nancy Pelosi talking
about this I didn't know that he would
be so sensitive he's always talking
about other people's of wild draw their
weight their pounds so that but I really
I don't even want to spend any more time
on his distraction because as you see in
the last several days so much of the
time has been spent on what he said
rather than that I think you should
recognize that his words weigh a ton his
words weigh a ton ha ha oh ha ha you get
it because he's because he's heavy he's
a fatty make fat Pat McFadden Andrew
Cuomo who has led whose great activities
in New York have led to the deaths of
presumably tens of thousands of elderly
people Andrew Cuomo was like Trump can't
tweet his way through this is picking up
on Joe by you know Joe Biden his term
Trump I will say Trump is gifted at
giving nicknames the man is gifted for a
sixth grader he's gifted at it like he's
amazing at it his nicknames are catchy
they are to the point right
sleepy Joe still works right thing
called nasty Nancy and he's got like all
of these various nicknames and they're
they're very good Joe Biden came up with
president we for Trump president Tweety
like the bird that doesn't what
seriously
Joba okay so here is Andrew Cuomo doing
his best he says to Trump you're not
tweeting your way through this Andrew
Cuomo was asked yesterday about nursing
home deaths and he was like it's just
because the media keep focusing on
nursing home deaths that I'm getting all
this flat here's the Andrew Cuomo the
world's worst governor talking about how
Trump can't tweet his way through this
but he can just talk his way through
this media will continue to kiss his ass
today government's gonna be held to a
different standard and it has to be
fundamentally different it has to be
smarter than it was it matters now what
happens you have to know what you're
doing now not just look like you know
what you're doing not just sound like
you know what you're doing you have to
be
smart you're not gonna tweet your way
through this you have to be smart you
have to be confident at what you do
there's something called government okay
Andrew Cuomo lecturing us all and being
smart and competent and the thing called
government I'm sorry no I'm gonna go no
on that Andrew Cuomo my goodness
run by a bunch of children it's
incredible this is why honestly like
allowing individuals to make their own
decisions and allowing individuals to
mitigate their own risk and allowing
individuals to actually be informed of
the information and then actually decide
for their own lives what is most
valuable I trust them more than any of
these people any of these people who
these people are you like aa man his
word is his bond her word is her bond
these are mature adults taking care of
us absolute insanity all right time for
some things that I hate in many many
things that I hate today so let's talk
about the economic response to
coronavirus so the federal government
has been shoving money out the door I
mean they took a fire hose they put
money in one end the fire hose is just
spraying money out to Americans an
extraordinary rate like far faster than
any time in history but now Democrats
are saying we need to know where the
money is going yet Democrats have never
cared for one iota of time where the
money is going now they're very
concerned why because there are two
tranches of money one went out to
individual American citizens
68% of Americans are currently being
paid more than they were being paid to
be employed to be unemployed okay now in
the short term that's fine right I mean
if they're know you're not employed
right now right you don't have a job so
that net that's okay and that's because
the government shut everything down but
as we move back into a functional
economy it is not good to pay people
more than they were making at their job
to sit at home on their couch that is
not sustainable that is not good it does
lead to a longer and slower economic
increase right that is that is a reality
Democrats are not worried about any of
that they want this unemployment policy
continued ad infinitum really really
forever so when President Trump says we
don't want to extend unemployment
benefits all the way out to January
because people are getting back to work
Democrats are responding no no we need
to do it forever forever House Democrats
have proposed extending the aid
January 2021 congressional Republicans
say they're concerned some workers are
making more money on unemployment
insurance than if they're on a payroll
and they have less incentive to return
to work or find a new job Lindsey Graham
said you can extend some assistance you
don't want to pay people more unemployed
than they'd make working you should
never make more than your actual wages
Graham said that Trump agrees that it is
hurting the economic recovery and then
of course the Washington Post goes to
many economists fear cutting off the
benefit extension could hamper the
economic recovery you're right paying
people not to work will hamper the
economic recovery again I'm all in favor
of filling in the gap that was created
by government forcibly shutting down the
entire economy and being put into a coma
but now that we are coming out of the
coma now would be the time where you
stop giving people the anesthetic at the
lunch from Hannah lunch with Senate
Republicans he implored Senate
Republicans to take their time on the
next phase of coronavirus list and
coronavirus legislation to get it right
which makes sense because we've just
been rushing these bills out the door
and the bills kind of suck I mean
they're the best you can do when you're
in a giant rush but they kind of suck
meanwhile harry reid who was responsible
along with nancy pelosi for holding up
the first two tranches of coronavirus
response is now saying why don't we have
a plan to get 36 million people back to
work we do have a plan you just don't
like that plan because your plan is do
not have them go back to work your plan
is to pay them to stay unemployed
forever mr. president why haven't you
announced a plan to get 36 million
unemployed Americans back to work you're
overseeing historic economic despair I
think we've announced a plan we're
opening up our country just a rude
person you are we're opening up our
country and we're opening it up very
fast the plan is that each state is
opening and it's opening up very
effectively and when you see the numbers
I think even you will be impressed which
is pretty hard to impress you good for
Trump honestly good for Trump but is it
is a ridiculous question that is not a
question why don't we have a plan for X
that's not a question that's an
accusation okay when Trump says no our
plan for the restored economy is to
reopen that is obviously true guess
whose plan that is everybody on earth
everybody on earths plan except
apparently for members of the media
whose plan for recovery is shovel money
out the door continuously and forever
meanwhile it's funny because again
Democrats are of two minds about the
shoveling money out the door on the one
they want to shovel money out the door
sufficient that people never have to go
back to work on the other hand they want
to not shovel money out the door to
businesses those businesses can continue
to function so the the heroes Act that
Democrats have been proposing basically
puts vast restrictions on businesses
that take business loans The Wall Street
Journal editorial board talks about the
first round of the bill which which
allowed the the Small Business
Administration and Treasury Department
to give forgivable loans to small
businesses Senate Democrats on Tuesday
lashed Treasury Secretary Stephen
minuchin and Federal Reserve chair
Jerome Pell for not doing enough to help
businesses and workers while warning
them not to bail out companies if you
want a prescription for a slow economic
recovery that would be it
Congress has appropriated five hundred
billion dollars to backstop federal
reserve lending facilities for mid-sized
and large companies as well as local
governments plus six hundred seventy
billion dollars for paycheck protection
program loans to small businesses these
funds were needed to keep businesses
liquid amid government ordered lock
downs so workers have jobs to return to
once the Pens attic recedes one problem
is minuchin has been too willing to bend
to Democrats who want to use the
business relief to attack the Trump
administration chief among the
requirements Democrats are focusing in
on is a requirement that businesses use
75 percent of loans for payroll in order
to qualify for loan forgiveness Treasury
says this mandate fulfills Congress's
apparent intents that loans be used to
retain workers but it has deterred many
small businesses and especially
restaurants with high overhead costs
from applying so Elizabeth Warren went
after minuchin on the spaces yesterday
so here is senator Elizabeth Warren who
again would love to completely remake
all businesses in America according to a
model that she apparently likes even
though she's never run a successful
business here is Elizabeth Warren
talking about we have to force
businesses to keep people employed so
we're gonna sign business as a check so
they can keep people employed when they
have no market to actually cater to
which of course is not how businesses
work I pointed out this flaw when these
bills were first passed that if you
aren't giving a loan to a small business
but the mandate on the small businesses
you have to keep 90 percent of your
people employed what exactly just pay
the people to be on unemployment
seriously because what you're actually
doing is you are forcing the business to
not pay its bills right you're not they
can't pay the landlord they can't pay
for the fixed costs you have to force
them to pay employees who literally
aren't you're banning them from working
so you're having the employers pay
employee
not to work well that's not sustainable
because guess what's gonna happen the
very first moment that the business is
open their doors if to fire all those
employees instead of put people on
unemployment if they cannot work right
now and then businesses can rehire them
as needed right that creates fluidity in
the market that allows you to actually
decide what the wages should be as the
market starts to come back because again
the market when it comes back is not
gonna be what it was when it originally
went down but according to the Democrats
they want every business that takes a
loan to have to use the vast majority of
the money it gets to pay employees who
are not working then what the hell is
the unemployment insurance for exactly
here is Elizabeth Warren going after
Steven Nugent what I want to know is are
you going to require companies that
receive money from this half a trillion
dollar slush fund to have to keep people
on payroll it's a simple question yes or
no are you're gonna require that first
let me say that our number one objective
is keeping people employed I take it
your answer to my question that whether
or not you're going to require as part
of the terms of the law that people be
kept on is no is that right secretary
minutiae that was discussed with people
on both sides of the aisle okay so he's
saying listen what's in the bill is in
the bill and she's saying well we need
to force you to force businesses to keep
people employed but again if you're a
business and you're thinking okay what's
gonna come next I have some fixed cost I
can maybe survive another two months but
what I can't do is take a loan from the
government that I then they have to
repay and now I'm in hock to the
government a bunch of money and I've
also lost my ability to fire employees
or furlough employees because you fire
furlough employees then the loans are
not forgivable so what's the point of me
taking out the loan I'd rather just lay
off the employees and then they can go
get them unemployment and then they can
come back when the time is right but
according to the Democrats they don't
want to give businesses loans to keep
them alive unless those businesses use
the loans to do stuff that Democrats
want which is not how business works
according to The Wall Street Journal
Treasury says that this mandate about 75
percent of loans being used for payroll
fulfills Congress's appearance intent
loans be used to retain workers but it
has deterred many small businesses
especially restaurants with high
overhead cost from
line minuchin has refused to relax the
requirement which our sources say is
because he doesn't want to get hammered
by democrats for letting businesses
prioritize paying landlords over workers
but again the goal of the business is to
pay its bills and to make one more
dollar than it expends the goal of
business is is not to create jobs this
is a full failure to understand how
economics works businesses create jobs
they buy products of catering to markets
businesses businesses do not create jobs
for fun and they do not do it out of the
goodness of their heart and they've not
paid workers out of the goodness of
their heart that would be a welfare
program or a charity program Treasury
and the Fed keep fiddling with the rules
for the Main Street lending facilities
including the stake that banks are
required to retain and loans they issue
as well as leverage limits for borrowers
minuchin said last month I think it's
pretty clear if Congress wanted me to
lose all the money that money would have
been designated as subsidies and grants
as opposed to credit support he
clarified it during Tuesday's hearing
that Treasury is willing to take losses
in certain scenarios such as and mr.
Powell says the Fed expects to have the
Main Street facility up and running by
the first week of June the businesses
needed the cash weeks ago even now many
will be reluctant to borrow because the
Fed has restrictions on pivot ins an
executive compensation and those
continued for a year after the loan is
repaid
so you repay the loan in the
government's still gonna control how you
run your business by the way all these
bans on stock buybacks if you like the
stock market actually having some
semblance of recovery if a company feels
that its stock is being undervalued a
stock buyback is actually a good policy
every rips on stock buybacks because
they don't understand that is a
government just investing in itself and
recognizing that the market is under
valuing its future prospects so again
this is the economic recovery is
dependent on markets Democrats are
looking to undermine markets because
Democrats don't like the markets and
they are blaming the markets for a
government insured and government
created crisis in the first place okay
other things that I hate today
so you on musk is now being raked over
the coals there's an incredible article
at The New York Times by Nellie Bowles
who's just an awful reporter I mean
she's just truly terrible she wrote one
of the worst profiles I've ever seen on
my friend Jordan Peterson in which he
accused Jordan Peterson of basically
wanting to force single women into
marriage and all sorts of crap like this
is an awful awful piece
Cinelli balls did awful journalist and
she has a piece today titled Tesla
owners tried to make sense of Elon
Musk's red pill moment a liberal status
symbol now has a founder who's moving to
the right Oh
oh wait and wait until wait until ford
owners find out that henry ford both
liked the free market but also was kind
of a nazi like wait until they find out
that Henry Ford was publishing like
full-on anti-semitic propaganda it was
given award by the Nazi government in
1938 wait until people find out that
Volkswagen and BMW were complicit in the
Nazi worship like wait until people find
out that a lot of Japanese automobile
companies were involved with the
Japanese imperialist government during
World War two
you mean the people buy products and
they like the products but they don't
care all that much what the founders
have to say about things unbel
it's not true now everybody who owns a
Tesla is reconsidering owning a Tesla
because of Elon Musk now um I just have
a question who who are these people
I know a bevy of people who owned
Tesla's I don't know a single one it by
the way many of them right-wing I don't
know a single one of them who is
reconsidering their Tesla purchase
because the Elon Musk has been tweeting
cancel cancel cancel culture on Twitter
or take the red pill on Twitter but
according to Nelly Bowles owning a tesla
luxurious electric car is a major
liberal status symbol it signals nothing
more than good taste the perfect balance
of wealth with care for fossil fuels but
the man behind the brand is crafting a
very different persona online that may
now prove to be a challenge for his fans
really because it seems like most of his
fans were kind of libertarian ish and
people who had a wild side Elon Musk the
bombastic head of Tesla and SpaceX
exhorted his 34 million Twitter
followers on Sunday to take the red pill
the comment was quickly embraced by his
followers including a banker trump
president from sold their daughter who
announced she had taken the pill already
the exchange referred to a scene from
the matrix the 1999 science fiction
action film but the meaning of red pill
and the idea of taking it have since
percolated in online forums and become a
deeply political metaphor so Tesla
owners are having to grapple with a car
that carries a few new connotations
Marcos mullets as' author of the
resistance handbook 45 ways to fight
Trump says honestly musk is becoming a
liability the tesla board needs to
seriously consider else ting him and I
say that as a proud owner of our Tesla
and SpaceX fanatic who truly appreciates
what he's built why are you quoting
Marcos mulet since the guy was like the
founder of daily Coast wire
why are you quoting Marcos melissa's as
though he is representative of Tesla
owners everywhere the guy is a rabid
leftist marcos Mallette says he has been
for like his entire career that's like
saying
that you found a rep that you found out
that Alex Jones owns a Prius and now
he's really pissed to find out that the
Prius is an environmentalist symbol and
what are you talking about
Nellie bones just offices in the matrix
the movies hero neo played by Keanu
Reeves is given the option to take a
pill that lets him see the truth the
world he thinks is real turns out to be
an entertaining lie his body is actually
trapped in a farm where people are being
used as human batteries taking the blue
pill would let him return to living in
the ignorant but blissful eye while
taking the red pill would launch him
into the arduous journey through a
brutal but fulfilling reality the idea
of taking the red pill later grew to
mean waking up to society's grand lies
it was embraced by the right especially
by members of its youngest cohort who
organized and spent their time in online
forums like rented and 4chan the truth
to be woken up to vary but it ended up
being usually about gender to be red
pill meant that you discovered feminism
was a scam that ruined the lives of boys
and girls in this view for a male to
refuse the red pill was to be weak red
pill forms were often filled with deeply
misogynistic an office racist diatribes
okay so now we're gonna play the game or
because you on musk said take the red
pill he is actually an in cell but what
you want most by saying take the red
pill what he doesn't mean is we need to
reopen the economy in responsible
fashion and get back to work
instead Elon Musk is hanging out on
4chan and being a Nazi according to
Nelly balls what is her evidence for
this that the term red pill is sometimes
used by people on 4chan boards
unbelievable as these conversations
seeped into the mainstream pulled along
by a host of other internet language
from message boards to establishment
Republican conversations on sites like
Breitbart the meaning broaden and got
watered down to be read pelled Canal
being broadly skeptical of experts to be
distrustful of the mainstream press or
to see Apocrypha and social liberalism
okay why don't just say that why do you
have to go through the etymology of red
pill the reason you go through the
etymology of red pill is because what
you're attempting to do is it force link
Elon Musk's the most radical aspects of
these and so Nellie Bowles goes on for
hundreds more words talking about the
evils of Elon Musk and then she quotes
Lily wachowski a matrix co-creator who
told mr. musk and Miss Trump and
colorful language on Twitter they could
take a hike and then I like this his red
pill a Silicon Valley thing to some
extent there's long minutes train
immense right activism in Silicon Valley
and this is a long ridiculous piece
about the history of red pelling because
musk used the term red pill and what
what is this really this is we have to
shame
musk the same way that we shamed mozilla
firefox' into firing brendan ice the
same way that we are now going after
catherine herridge anybody who is in a
perceived liberal occupation and was
betrayed betrayed a particular set of
elites they must be cast out like a
leper Elon Musk's sin he didn't sit like
Nellie Bowles had nothing to say about
this when Elon Musk was on Joe Rogan
smokin dope right like that he had
nothing to say about that which by the
way there was like a temporary drop in
the stock price and then it spiked again
but she has lots to say about the fact
that Elon Musk may politically disagree
with Nellie Bowles and whoa whoa we
can't have that you mean ahead of a
major company disagreeing with Nellie
bulls that means you got to sell your
Tesla gang you got to sell it the same
way that we had to boycott SoulCycle
when it turned out that one of the
owners of SoulCycle was a Trump fan oh
man now again this sort of cent story is
bullcrap from the same people who
proclaim that they are for free speech
and open debate is truly astonishing and
they do it to members of the media to
I'll to talk about Trump undermining the
media today there are multiple articles
out about the evils of Catherine
Harridge what does Catherine Harridge is
great sin catherine herridge is great
sentence she once worked at Fox News and
she was reported on the Michael Flynn
story and so we have seen people in the
media smearing catherine herridge
according to Jonathan Tobin over at the
New York Post and this is exactly
correct
journalists are pack animals that's
especially true in Washington that's
what makes CBS is catherine herridge so
exceptional in an era when too many
network journalists lanten reporting to
serve establishment opinion Harwich six
to the fact her sterling quality and
integrity have also put a target on her
back when it came to the collusion hoax
she turns to let the truth guide her wet
clothes with her reporting into the
government misconduct in the prosecution
of President Trump's first national
security adviser Michael Flynn most of
her colleagues reveled in collusion
falsehoods and ignored FBI wrongdoing
she did the opposite but there is a
price to refusing to conform
Abidin flack named Andrew Bates called
her a partisan right-wing hack a scarlet
story appeared in The Daily Beast in
which various CBS journalists speaking
anonymously voiced their disgust with
her for not sharing their partisan
prejudices this has also happened to
journalists like Cheryl Atkinson who is
basically cast out of mainstream media
for the great crime of reporting things
that the media didn't like them
reporting meanwhile people like Ronan
Farrow who as it turns out is a
journalist who has driven more by
ideology than by good journalistic
practices he is hailed as a hero
because of course he reinforces all the
things the media want to be true in the
world
so catherine herridge very bad for
putting out actual news Ronan Farrow
very good because he targeted Matt Lauer
and because he targeted Harvey Weinstein
so the target mattered more than the
journalistic practices by the way worth
noting today Matt Lauer being raked over
the coals for writing a piece for media
pointing out all the flaws of reporting
in Ronan Farrow
okay now you notice like Matt Lauer you
can think Matt Lauer's of scuzzbag
sounds to me like Matt Lauer's goes bad
but he points out that Ronan Farrow his
reporting on Matt Lauer quote
consistently failed to confirm stories
told to him by his main sources failed
to provide evidence of important
communications he alleged it took place
between accusers and me he says in most
cases Ronan doesn't even claim to have
personally seen evidence of those
communications used misleading language
to manipulate readers into believing
things that could easily be false or at
least unprovable in some cases he
undeniably withheld information from the
reader that would call the credibility
of sources into question and according
to Matt Lauer who routinely presents its
stories in a way that would suit his
activist goals as opposed to any kind of
journalistic standard specifically
specifically Lauer is upset with the way
that Ronan Farrow covered the rape
allegation by Brooke nevels okay and he
points out like a thousand flaws with
Ronan Farrow is reporting that are
legitimate flaws you don't have to like
you can think Matt Lauer is a scuzzbag
who sexually harassed the help a rape
allegation is a pretty damn serious
thing and if you're gonna make that
allegation then you'd best do your
research beforehand according to
according to Matt Lauer that never
happened according he quotes Ronan
Farrow in his book catch and kill says
nevels told a million people about Lauer
she told her inner circle of friends she
told colleagues and superiors it's an
NBC she was never in consistent she made
the seriousness of what happened clear
Lauer says does Ronan offer any proof of
this claim does he say he confirmed this
story with any of the friends or
colleagues she claims to have told about
the seriousness of what she alleges
happened does he include a single
comment or quote from a corroborating
source for these claims he does not did
he tried to track down the superior at
NBC that she talked to did he include a
quote or comment from that superior
did he find out if the superior had been
told about the seriousness of what
Brooke claims he did not how do I know
says Matt Lauer because I did it took me
15 minutes to find out who the boss was
that nevels had supposedly reported to
he says I contacted Sharon Scott
Sharon concerns you might not have been
aware of a serious situation involving a
member of her staff
contacted Brooks direct superior and
they spoke at length that new boss told
sure and Scott that one night Brooks
simply stated talking started talking
about having an affair with me she said
most importantly Brooke never said a
single word about this being anything
but a consensual affair she said Brooke
in no way conveyed the seriousness of
what she now claims the superior says
Ronan Farrow never reached out to her to
confirm the story that referenced her in
the book hey like Matt Lauer or hate
Matt Lauer believed Matt Lauer or don't
believe Matt Lauer the reality is that
because Ronan Farrow targeted the right
people and Matt Lauer is a bad guy Ronan
Farrow was able to get away with bad
journalistic practices by the way Ronan
Pharos response to Matt Lauer was
incredibly dismissive he didn't bother
to actually respond to the immediate
allegations made by Matt Lauer he
basically just said Matt Lauer's a
meaning that was his his essential
response so you know that again here was
his only tweet all I'll say on this is
that Matt Lauer is just wrong catching
kill was thoroughly reported in fact
checks including with Matt Lauer himself
okay how about some responses do
specific allegations made my battle our
he makes some pretty specific
allegations there how about bringing
forth your sources
hey those are pretty specific
allegations but of course people
celebrated Ronan Farrow owning Matt
Lauer because he didn't even respond to
the allegations again this is not City
Matt Lauer is in a sense if the charges
made against him it is to say it is not
a response to say I don't like Matt
Lauer he's mean and I stand by my
reporting if someone makes a specific
allegation he didn't call somebody you
need to bring forward the person you
talked to that would be the normal
journalistic practice but is the way
works in the media you confirm people's
belief systems and you get away with it
you cross them and you become Catherine
Herridge or cheryl atkinson all righty
we'll be back here later today with two
additional hours of content otherwise
we'll see you here tomorrow I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
assistant director Pavel I douse key
technical producer Austin Stevens
playback and media operated by Nick
Sheehan associate producer Katie Swinton
edited by Adam SCI events audio is mixed
by Mike Cora Mina
hair and makeup is by Anika Geneva the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh oh it's not just
another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen